for some children in north las vegas
having internet at home is just not an
option
last year the city of north las vegas
opened micro classrooms to help students
with distance learning and this month
those classrooms expanded to a third
location hector mejia live this morning
near bruce and owens with a live look at
one of those classrooms hector good
morning
hey there john good morning and this is
one of those three brand new locations
well this is one of the three locations
this is the newest one
operated by the city of north las vegas
this is the neighborhood rec
center and this place has been
transformed into a classroom and here
you see part of it right here
joining us live we have ashley campbell
with the nevada action for school
options and they help the city sort of
develop the lesson plans here good
morning to you good morning thank you
thanks for having us so early so tell us
you know how has this been helping
students
sort of catch up with their schoolwork
when they were struggling at home maybe
without internet or not having any
guidance at all from a teacher
it's been really great to see the kiddos
coming in and the help that they're
receiving here we have our live
instructors
in the rooms our guides they're working
with the kiddos developing individual
plans
they have the students are accessing
self-directed learning software
through the computer which is part of
their individual plan and then they also
are doing live instruction with the
coaches and whole group lessons and we
have a demo right here we have
calvin sitting right there your son and
we also have elliot
elliott here is in grade number three
tell us what are you learning right now
you're
you've been focused this entire morning
um
right now i'm learning um
what's like how people learn time
when it was like when we didn't have
clocks
and i'm and i'm reading and filling in
the blanks
so she's learning about a time in
history when people did not have clocks
what do you think about that um it's
pretty cool and
i like how they under
and i like how they use like night and
day
in the shadows to tell the time and good
job you did 144 words per minute
that's really cool so uh students need
to be residents in north las vegas or
they need to uh be a
children of first responders we'll go
over those requirements
in half an hour for now reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now back to you guys
oh my goodness they're so cute hector
yeah good stuff hector and
make sure they stay on their on their
task there don't let them
let up here that's good stuff hector
they'll catch up with you later not
interrupt